oh you know good listen a little birdie
told me you're gonna bout to turn 80 on
February 19 it's a blessing come on what
are you doing what are you drinking what
are you eating what are you doing I need
all this I don't know but I tell people
it's the best because I feel 40 you know
is it so so 80 is the new 40 absolutely
for me that what a big night it is
tonight always on Grammy night I mean
you're a staple here well you know I'm
proud to be here you know this music
night and so I hope that under the
circumstances we'll have as good a time
as possible yeah under the circumstances
this is a tough night for everybody just
your thoughts when people are mourning
and not really knowing how to make sense
of it all absolutely and as a dad man I
look at that it had to be really rough
for his baby to be on the plane with him
on the helicopter my god that's horrible
we're here at the house that in a lot of
ways Kobe built Staples Center what are
you you know just his legacy what do you
what do you have to say about well he
left a legacy and that's for sure he was
one of the greatest sports figures that
we've ever had I mean not just for Los
Angeles but for sports period so he's
going to be highly missed by everyone
and I've seen people just groan me and
crying today about it you know I cried
because he's my friend and it's rough
but I'm doing the best I can have a good
time tonight we're here to celebrate
music and I hope that we can do that and
hopefully they can honor him in some way
during this show too I hope so I'm sure
that they'll arrange something all right
yeah
[Music]